situation très difficile dans les
récoltes de grain particulièrement du
maïs le nay la neige le froid et les
vents perturbe les récoltes selon les
données de la financière agricole
seulement 26 % des récoltes de maïs
était complétée le 12 novembre dernier
l'an dernier on était à 48 % le 6
novembre 2018 à 83% le 20 novembre
l'année précédente on est à 56 % le 14
novembre 2017 et 15 novembre 2016 on
était à 75 %
les producteurs de grains demande de
l'aide avec nous benoît legout directeur
général des producteurs de grains du
québec bonsoir vous demander une
rencontre d'urgence mais qui n'a pas eu
lieu aujourd'hui c'est le 26 novembre
c'est ça avec les ministres vulture pour
lui demander quoi bon on fait pour aider
les producteurs à faire face à cette
crise
cette situation exceptionnelle qui crée
beaucoup de traits de détresse ou au
sein des communautés agricoles
c'est assez exceptionnel pour les
producteurs de voir encart leurs grains
leurs revenus leur potentiel de revenus
dans le champ aussi tard on parle ici
quand même dans une production de trois
corps
2 milliards de dollars quand y en a
cinquante l'on parle de 114 on se
concentrait peut-être autour de 60
depuis les derniers jours il y avait
quand même eu un peu d'avancement mais
c'est très dur c'est avec une raie 60 %
du maïs n'est pas vrai que je sais c'est
un chiffre que je vous lance comme ce
soir on me dit que ça avance à coups de
4 5% par jour depuis le 12 13 14
novembre
habituellement quand les conditions sont
idéales on peut parler de 10 12% à 13%
par jour qu'est ce qui fait que c'est
difficile en ce moment la neige le vent
techniquement qu'est ce qui fait que
c'est difficile comme vous l'avez
expliqué plus tôt c'est la neige et le
froid les moissonneuses batteuses et
pour un équipement qui est fait pour
travailler dans ces conditions la neige
cause problème parce qu'elle entre dans
le système de nettoyage et ça affecte
leur tout le mécanisme de nettoyage des
grains ça peut amener des bris
d'équipement ce qu'on voit beaucoup
d'ailleurs certains producteurs me
disais ce week-end qui passe plus de
temps au garage autant garage que dans
les rues sont donc certains producteurs
préfèrent ralentir et attendre qu'il se
passe quelque chose qui leur permettra
d'avoir accès sans avoir à récolter dans
la neige mais les conditions qui sont
prévues au cours des prochains jours
on sent bien qu'il y va s'est bien
installé puis ce qui est peut être un
peu dangereux c'est que tout revers à
l'envers c'est à dire que cette neige la
semaine soit à fond dès qu'il ya de la
pluie parce que c'est les conditions
deviennent trop humide s'est proposé
pour la machine et se déplacer la nuit
sont donc toujours seul le maïs perdrait
de sa qualité s'il a déjà perdu de sa
qualité vous rappelle qu'on ne se
mettraient à tort de trois semaines de
retard à cause des pluies il froid ont
jamais été rattrapé au cours du
de l'été il était était quand même moyen
peut-être un peu en bas de la moyenne en
terme de communication de chaleur et
d'ensoleillement
on se retrouve le 31 octobre avec des
vents de puissants vents en une et en
électricité données dans les champs oui
ça lui son effet sur des tissus est un
peu affaibli contenu de la paix de
l'année difficile de semis de croissance
est là bas le sommet nuit est brisée en
partie il se retrouve beaucoup plus plus
près de la neige homme sonne mal mais
c'est plus élevé là il se retrouve plus
peur de la neige ou dans la neige
alors ça versa on attend donc des pertes
assurées pour vous les pertes assurées
pour les producteurs de maïs
oui il ya des pertes déjà qu'on
s'entende en baisse de rendement on
s'attend à ce que des epic puisse pas
être récoltés il ya un phénomène qu'on a
vu aussi ses des épis qui se décrochent
au litige compte tenu des conditions
climatiques
donc ce soir quelques les pertes de
rendement avec des effets sur les
producteurs de porcs les producteurs de
boeuf qui ont besoin de cette nourriture
pour les animaux
oui en effet le mail c'est une portion
importante que dans la fabrication des
aliments pauvres le troupeau par st pour
la volaille pour les animaux pour les
bovins mais évidemment on est dans un
marché nord-américain même international
est toujours possible d'en importer
c'est des choses qui arrivent car demain
c'est devant une qualité au québec et
mais ça a été très peu fréquent dans les
derniers aimeraient qu'on n'ait pas
atteint notre stand heures de garrett de
mes plus cette année beaucoup de grade 3
4 5 et plus on descend moins essayer de
qualité en orange mais ces champions
donc leur besoin de mélange mais le
problème c'est que les états limitrophes
américains de haut on s'approvisionne on
vous en parle au peut-être plus tard
mais ils y ont eu des problèmes mais
aussi l'ontario ou si les problèmes de
qualité de l'école
le ministre de l'agriculture andrée
lamontagne je dis aujourd'hui que la
financière agricole offre des programmes
d'assurance récolte en fait c'est simple
c'est sa réponse à vous de dire bay à ce
programme là est ce que ce programme là
il suffisant
ce programme là sera toujours
insuffisant c'est un joueur dans sa
forme actuelle
il impose aux routeurs une franchise de
20 %
20 % sur sept fins millions de valeur on
se rend compte que 140 millions c'est
déjà beaucoup
c'est beaucoup d'argent mais le
programme français le premier fait pour
ça n'est pas couvert c'est une franchise
donc sur une ferme de ce cent mille
dollars ou 2 millions c'est une
franchise de 120 amis ou 200 mille
dollars donc c'est assez important
c'est là le programme existe comme tel
on cherche à l'améliorer depuis quelques
années et pour l'instant pour la
prochaine rencontre ce qu'on cherche
obtenez c'est cette salle sur x qui est
déjà en place on l'utilisé de façon
optimale le programme d'assurance
récolte il ya des normes d'application
on est dans des zones grises beaucoup
cette année en termes de d'abandon de
chant ou de qualité comme je l'aï
mentionné plus tôt
tant que des choses à faire à
l'intérieur des enveloppes qui sont déjà
prêts prévus mais je vous cache pas que
compte tenu que les coûts de récolte
sont très élevés et ses charges
il y aura une demande aussi pourvoir à
supporter c'est cool c'est donc une
demande spéciale
oui supplémentaires de combien si le sel
évaluer le présentement je pourrais pas
vous donner de chiffres on n'est pas
dans les 100 millions de dollars
peut-être quelques dizaines de millions
le programme d'assurance récolte va
faire un bout pour les pertes qu'ils
vont lors du premier vingt pour ça mais
toute la question de la qualité des
grains qui est pas couverts ainsi qui
n'est pas couverte et les coûts quelques
dizaines de millions mais je peux pas
vous dire exactement en fait c'est déjà
ça monsieur legault merci beaucoup merci
merci